هي المركز الصفر والاساسي والارتكاز لهذا
الزلزال هذه المدينه التي وصلناها منذ
ثلاثه منذ ثلاثه ساعات هي تختلف عن
الولايات الاخرى هي مدينه سياحيه بامتياز
ولكن بدات الحياه تعود وتدب اليها كما
نشاهد الان هذه حركه السيارات في الشوارع
الرئيسيه في المدينه بالاضافه ايضا الى
طقس المدينه حيث نرى الثلج على الارصفه
ولكن ان المختلف في هذه المدينه هو ان
الزلزال قام باختيار الابنيه كما يشاء
لذلك اذا اخذنا ايضا هذا الشارع وعلى طوله
لامتداد خمسه الى سته كيلو مترات لربما
تجد الى انه سبعه
بنايات هي صالحه لم يعصف بها الزلزال ولكن
تجد بنايه من اولها الى اخرها قد سقطت على
الارض ثم بعد ذلك الصوره على هذا الى اخر
الشارع وهذا ايضا يتوقف عنده كما اشرت
ويدلل عليه بقضيه الانشاءات اذا دخلنا الى
هذا الشارع كما نشاهد على يمين يبدو انه
بانك ولكن ايضا في المقلب الاخر هنالك
ابنيه سكنيه ولكن اذا اخذنا الصوره مباشره
الى حيث هذا المسجد نرى هذه الابنيه
المتكدسه فوق بعضها البعض ونرى ايضا هذه
الكتل الاسمنتيه الممزوجه بحاجات الناس
واغراضهم واثاث منازلهم الى الاسمنت ايضا
والى ايضا كل ما هو كان في هذه المنازل
التي تركها اهلها منهم بطبيعه الحال من
توفي او منهم من نقل الى منطقه اخرى ومنهم
من اصبح في المستشفى اذا اخذنا الصور
نشاهد ايضا كيف ان هذه الكتل قد اغلقت هذا
النفق الذي نحن فوقه وايضا
ما بين ولايه واخرى نشاهد هذا الجليد الذي
نتحدث عن تحت الصفر في هذه المنطقه والذي
بطبيعته الحال كان له تدعيه سلبيه على
عمليات رفع الانقال لاننا نتحدث عن اثنين
الى ثلاثه تحت الصفر قمنا بجوله في ارجاء
المدينه لكي نتوقف عندها وعليها هل ان
هنالك من ورش لا زالت قائمه او من فرق
للمتطوعين ولكن يظهر الى ان المدينه قد
نالت الجزء القليل من بين الولايات
التركيه وعليه الى ان الابنيه المتهدمه
والتي سميت مع الارض تعمل في بعض منها او
في بعض الاماكن منها الجرافات والشاحنات
على نقل الانقاذ الى خارج المدينه وعلى
ايضا فصل هذا الانقاذ حيث شاهدنا وينع
قرب شاحنات تنقل ايضا الحديد لوحده وتنقل
الاتربه لوحدها في ارجاء المدينه وما بين
احيائها الداخليه في الحدائق العامه نصبت
المئات من الخيام التي يقطنها بطبيعه
الحال في هذه المدينه الجل الاكبر من
المواطنين الاتراك وقله قليله من النازحين
او اللاجئين السوريين كما هي في الوصول من
ولايه الى هذه المدينه قرابه 300 كيلو متر
مجتازنا العديد من القرى التركيه الصغيره
والتي ايضا في بعض منها ما نجا وفي بعض
منها الاخر من اتى عليه الزلزال فاكله
اكلا تلاحظ الى انه الفرق بين هنا وبين
الى انها البنايات في تلك المحله قد سقطت
من اعلاها الى ولكن هنا نرى ان الاخاديد
التي كانت من عصر الزلزال قد قلب
البنايات او قلب المنازل من اساسها واتكات
بعضها على بعضها الاخر وبقيت سالمه في
الطوابق العليا وهذا ايضا يدلل واعود معك
الى قضيه الانشاءات وهنا الغرابه لماذا ان
هذا الزلزال ياكل بنايه دون الاخرى يحطم
حيا دون الاخر يعصف ممكن هذا يعني